this video is sponsored by skillshare hi
everyone welcome to phase 17 of man
carrying thing Universe I make a lot of
silly
um videos and whatnot but did you know
that this channel started out making
book stuff well I still do that and No
One's Gonna Stop Me I don't know why I
was aggressive with that it's not that
serious first I'm going to talk about
the big series I've been tearing through
we talk about my experience with that
then I'm going to talk about some of the
other books I've been reading then I'm
going to try out a new segment uh called
bookmail which is heavily inspired by Mr
Daniel be green and very grateful for
anyone who sends me anything at all
anyways the books so in another video I
talked a lot about the Parker series and
I think in that video I had only gone
through the first five or six well I
have been tearing through those
especially in the month of March Parker
series is a series of books by Richard
Stark AKA Donald Westlake hard-boiled
crime fiction begun in the 60s and ended
in the early 2000s I mean there's 24 or
25 just Parker books and I hope that
through my reading of them I'm getting
others to read them because they should
not be overlooked in the crime genre in
the classic Noir genre they really stand
out Westlake as a writer really shines
in these books it may seem like they
would recycle things and the Parker
series does in a way because they're all
typically Heist stories but in heists
that go wrong and whatnot but they
typically follow the same structure but
it's kind of like a classic it's like a
classical music bring new depth to the
characters to the situation put Parker
into increasingly more perilous
situations and how to keep it grounded
and real it's incredible and part of
what makes the series so fascinating is
figuring out the limits of Parker's
capabilities you know he's This
brilliant skilled Thief cold-blooded
killer he hardly seems human he's like
an alien part of the suspense of the
series is figuring out how far his
empathy goes you know how human is he
and it's always fun so I read of course
the score one of the best books in the
series Parker number six the the Jugger
I enjoyed the Jugger quite a bit it's
not a typical Heist thing a lot of the
book you're kind of going what the hell
is even going on Parker's trying to
figure Parker's behind on things and
it's very funny because people keep
approaching him and are like hey are you
in on this thing like this Heist like I
know you know and he's like he has no
idea what's going on but he plays along
because he wants to figure out what
everyone's going on about this hundred
thousand dollars and everything um and
also like a creepy depiction of a small
town cop a great villain I mean part of
what keeps the Parker series interesting
are these fantastic villains that he
brings in there before we get on to the
next book I do want to talk about
skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
inspiring classes for creators explore
new skills deep and existing passions
and get lost in creativity with
skillshare you know a lot of people ask
me questions about building an online
presence or or creating videos and
content and trying to start like a
business out of it and I have such
little advice for for that because I
feel like I stumbled into this but I
have found some actually very helpful
courses on skillshare I do want to share
discovering success seven exercises to
uncover your purpose passion and path by
Emma Gannon I found this one applied a
lot to what I've learned over the years
now doing YouTube I also enjoyed
productivity for artists organizing
yourself for success by Brooke Glaser I
have a really hard time with
organization and hitting deadlines and
etc etc so I found this a nice refresher
you might know a skillshare for classes
in photography film and video editing
and illustration but did you know that
skillshare has hundreds of career
focused classes too traditional jobs are
not one size fits all learn how to
design a career to fit you 2023 that's
the year to reinvent your goals and
yourself I find myself browsing the
website constantly finding new stuff I
want to do they've been a fantastic
sponsor for this channel for quite a
while now you can do it in bite size
videos or watch the full course it's
curated specifically for learning
meaning there are no ads they're always
launching new premium classes so you can
stay focused skillshare now offers
classes in Spanish French Portuguese and
German the first thousand people to
click on the link in the description get
skillshare for free for one month it's a
fantastic deal do it learn something new
all right now we're going back to the
books then there's the seventh which to
me the seventh is probably my favorite
in the series terrific ending just great
Pace it's one of those Parker books
where the heist goes horribly wrong and
they're having to hunt down someone you
know and um then the handle which is the
eighth book uh I didn't enjoy quite as
much because it seemed more like a setup
for a spin-off series the growfield
series The Handle like an Espionage
story and I I appreciate the variety
because there is Variety in the books I
like getting to see Parker as like a
James Bond sort of character except he's
way more evil and I won't say evil but
he's way more like um doesn't care about
anything
um except for just doing the work and
getting the job done he is the apex of
the Protestant work ethic it is kind of
like outlandish I honestly thought it
was a little thin I thought it could
have felt a little more believable if it
was there was a little more you know to
it but it was entertaining nonetheless I
do have it currently as my least
favorite Parker book but I still enjoyed
it so that says something about how much
I love the series that my least favorite
book I think is still a pretty good read
now at this point Westlake uh changed
Publishers he moved to pocketbooks I
believe or no he didn't move to
pocketbooks he moved to Gold Medal I
think I like when whenever he changed
Publishers he always kind of had a
change for the market and I liked seeing
the development of these stories as they
kind of fit in with like the realities
of the publishing industry all very slim
and very fun reads but this run is known
for the score books they're they're
known for their kind of humanizing they
look at Parker there's more humanizing
stuff and people some people dislike
this part in the series because he
becomes more human I disagree I just
think that there's more of that suspense
of Westlake asking how far can I push
Parker towards empathy how human is he
you know and testing him in these
different scenarios for example the
first of the score books Parker number
nine the rare coin score introduces a
love interest Claire who ends up being
His companion basically for the rest of
the series she goes in and out of the
books The Rare Coin score didn't love it
was fine it just felt a little dry there
was no great villain that I enjoyed that
much then the green Eagle score is
fantastic there's even scenes where like
a therapist is trying to understand this
Parker character you know everything
goes wrong in a a brilliant way but they
rob an Air Force Base it's great one of
my favorites the green Eagles score then
we have the black ice score the black
ice score is interesting because it
involves like the politics of an African
nation and they're trying to steal a
certain Diamond because there's these
nationalists and so there's like some
more sort of like the handle and sort of
like the mourner there's some political
Intrigue going on I thought the book was
pretty great actually this one gets
criticized a lot I didn't like that
Claire was sort of just Damsel in
Distress and her stuff wasn't as fleshed
out by the end Westlake was trying to
just wrap things up super fast and I
wasn't super into how it ended it just
felt a little rushed or whatever or
maybe I was just done with the book by
that point but not one of the best but
also not horrible and then the last of
the gold medal uh editions is uh the
sour lemon score I heard this one was
really good so I bought it in paperback
and it is good it is another one of
those uh Heist situations where things
just get worse and worse nothing goes
well there's some homicidal killers in
there Parker has to hunt people down
there's so much driving like Parker's
just scrambling always one step behind
he gets drugged you know it kind of
Bleak and to the point and I love it
when Stark slash West Lake goes there
and just sink into the the grime I mean
that's what I love with Noir and that's
what I love with these Parker books
sometimes there's more of the fantasy
but this one felt very down to earth and
gritty and I like that then uh just
recently at the 13th Parker book I've
read the 14th one sleigh ground I talked
about that another time slayground is
fantastic stick by the way but the 13th
Parker book is called deadly Edge this
is when paperback Originals were sort of
collapsing not collapsing but they
weren't as popular so Westlake switched
the Parker series into hardcover and you
feel that sense I mean it's it's a
longer book it's more fleshed out
fleshed out and it feels like a
reintroduction to new readers reading
maybe the hardcover the First Act is
fantastic it's all just one chapter most
of the books are split into just four
parts the First Act is just a wonderful
Heist of a rock concert and I really
love this because it's 1971 and things
are starting to change I mean Parker is
like a character from the 60s he's more
like a character from the 30s in a way
the opinions about like rock concerts in
the 70s and The Counter Culture was very
funny felt very um like once upon a time
in Hollywood Claire Parker's partner is
um you know kidnapped by these psychotic
uh drug acid-taking hippies who
portrayed as totally unhinged and I I
thought it was really fun it I thought
the writing was really strong deadly
Edge was good so yeah that's the Parker
series I'm I'm continuing to read it so
the next ones are plunder Squad and
butcher's Moon and then there's like a
25-year gap before he picked it up with
uh comeback besides Donald Westlake I'm
sorry I I can't help it sometimes I've
been reading so much Donald Westlake um
I read a wonderful self-published book
called seasons of albadon completely
different from hard-boiled Noir fiction
this was a fantasy story it was sort of
like a collection of four stories or
novellas it was a short book really
surprising I heard good stuff about it
online I actually had a chance to meet
the one of the authors I thought that
there was a nice kind of fable quality
to it but also it leaned into the
darkness you know there there was a a
kind of lesson in each story but it it
wasn't all about that they are Loosely
connected so it creates a hole there's a
sequel that I plan to read and it's
longer it seems more like a a novel than
the first one if you want to get into a
really quality self-published I mean
self-publishing industry I mean
sometimes you'll find writing that isn't
super polished this was quite polished I
had some issues with the writing sort of
slow in some places but regardless it
ended up capturing my imagination there
were some really fun scenarios like
World building wise and I really got to
care for the characters in a way that
you don't always get with short fantasy
stories yeah it's a really promising
Series so I'll let you know when I read
the second one then I read and just
finished cat's cradle Kurt Vonnegut I
picked this up at Goodwill I have only
read Slaughterhouse Five and that was
years ago I was in high school I have
very vague memories of Slaughterhouse
Five but I just never got into Vonnegut
I honestly think I was too young and
wasn't able to appreciate like the the
humor the political humor cat's cradle
was genuinely funny like I I laughed at
a couple points and I'd never do that
when I read super clever but it you know
it has this wrong it has a way of
writing that super so much is packed in
there it's very dense and the characters
feel sometimes one-dimensional sometimes
more than one dimensional
three-dimensional filled with ideas and
humor and Vonnegut has such a cynical
view of humanity but is able to
appreciate appreciate it at the same
time if it was very um it made me happy
I don't know how what other way to put
it even though it is a book about like
the end of the world but also a product
of its time the 60s the female
characters are not fleshed out at all
very dated uh you know racist uh
stereotypes and but you know factoring
in the time it was written it's it still
holds up and has a lot to say about the
present world uh cat's cradle I I
recommend it really liked it finally I'm
going to loop back around to Donald
Wesley and talk about 361 is one of his
earlier novels that he wrote under his
own name but before he wrote under his
own name he wrote uh like uh softcore
erotica but three 361 I was captivated
by seeing an image of the original cover
really a precursor to the Parker series
the main character is and I'm pretty
sure he wrote the hunter the same year
but you feel like this is a preview for
the hunter the Hunter's more Bleak and
and and Parker is a more intense
character but this one had a really kind
of sad interesting Dynamic with like
fatherhood and trying to find your
identity I think you want the more you
read Westlake the more you find out how
a lot of his books are about identity
and self-knowledge and figuring out who
you truly are so there's like Universal
themes there and this was a like Mafia
story
um before The Godfather like popularized
a lot of stereotypes we have about the
the mob like hard-boiled very
hard-boiled and pretty violent book
um and a lot of like tragedy happens in
it an easy book to read I mean it's it's
very entertaining you want to know how
it all unfolds I will say I thought the
ending was a bit anti-climatic bloody
cover and you hope it's gonna end
himself some kind of massive gory
bloodbath but it was a little more
restrained I did enjoy it quite a bit on
to our next segment this is something
new called mail
um I'm just going to be talking about
the stuff that people have sent me you
have sent me reminder the P.O box is in
the description of this video If you
ever are inclined to send me your book
or someone's book appreciate all the
notes and everything so every imagine
Tundra I have read a couple of the poems
I haven't read the whole thing but
really like it so far thank you for
sending me this I'm not going to share
anyone's names you know for whoever sent
me things but this person sent me a
really lovely note and a book that I
haven't heard of but sounds really
interesting called have have by Jan
Morris which is like a experimental
science fiction something I mean it's
it's something very interesting that I
really want to get into with an
introduction by Ursula Kayla Gwen so I'm
very interested I love you know the New
York Review book series so this author
Jules polarski I've heard of this writer
on Twitter or something so when I saw
this I recognized the cover and I'm
really into the style of this book it
feels I think it's like Choose Your Own
Adventure sort of thing and it looks
really fun I'm gonna read this soon and
I'll let you know what I think of it one
of the first books anyone has sent me
was called let's see guardians of Erin
or rebirth in the book they sent me a
screenshot of me replying saying I'm
gonna read their book I thought that was
really funny so I'm definitely gonna
read this I mean some of these like
self-published books they have really
high quality covers and whatnot it's
it's really fantastic this one is from a
small publishing press I believe this
sounds really interesting I started it
and I'm really into the vibe it's it's
very well written and kind of a surreal
way there's like a this imaginary
Eastern European country and the city
and these expats living there and their
their friendship and it has a kind of
um fun zany energy that I'm really
vibing with so I I look forward to
finishing this another author reached
out to me and and told me about their
book and I said yeah please send it this
is called the evening hero just barely
started it and I do uh plan to finish it
soon from what I know it's about a
Korean doctor there's some dark past
um it's been receiving a ton of Praise
And I I look forward to getting it so
thank you for sending that I really hope
I'm not forgetting anything this is just
from the last few months thank you so
much to everyone who sends me anything a
note a book I mean I love discovering
new self-published books I'll um get to
them when I get to them so thank you
everyone for that I hope you enjoyed the
bookmail section I already opened them I
wasn't going to wait and open them on
camera sorry I don't have the
self-control for that once again thank
you to my patrons for supporting the
channel always I mean you guys are so
lovely for for doing that and I also
want to thank skillshare of course for
sponsoring this video don't forget to
click on that link because it's a like a
really good deal yeah so that's what
I've been reading what have you been
reading tell me what you're up to
parasocial friend let me know what stuff
I should read I promise I am going to
read War breaker I'm reading it now
there's just a lot to read also I'm
finishing the Dark Tower soon I promise
all right I think that's everything
thank you all for watching and I will
see you all
soon bye bye